when should a writer decide if they're
writing a crime series or a standalone
story
most literary agents are looking for
writers
who can deliver a series because there's
longevity to that most Publishers are
looking for writers who can deliver a
series because they're long there's
longevity and when you start to invest
in a writer whether an agent or a
publisher like you it takes a lot to
invest into into in a writer so they
want writers who
they're this is a career this is
something they're going to be doing for
a while
um and going to be producing many works
so that they can foster this career and
make money so
I know when I've worked with my agent
almost everything we've pitched sold is
all based on a series
um almost everything uh now I know a lot
of Indie writers or hybrid authors and
they write series because when that's
the only way you can really make money
is if you're continuing to pump out the
next book and the next book in the next
book and it starts to gather like a
snowball down the mountain and then the
residuals you know and the money gets
bigger and bigger so
um
it's not it's not purely Financial but
also I most authors that I know that are
doing this
they really want to spend time in a
series they really want to develop a
character and keep it going and readers
love that readers want that they want to
invest and once they've invested in a
book or an author they want the next one
and the next you know if it's something
they really love and enjoy they want
more you know people will email me
readers will email me like when's the
next book coming when we want more of
Emily we want more what's happening so
there's there's a lot of reasons why I
think a series is a good choice a
standalone um I wrote a standalone it
and we published it in 2020. I that one
was a standalone because for me that was
a real passion project for me I never
saw it as a series and I was already
established as a an author and so I can
sort of take the risk you know of
publishing the standalone book Because I
had other things
in my repertoire
and I think the authors that I know that
have published standalones it's because
it's like that it's a passion project
it's something that really doesn't lend
itself to a series but it's something
they're very passionate about and they
they just need to write it and and
that's fine
um and my agent was fine with that but
you know okay but what's the next series
wait let's keep going so
is it easier to write a crime series
than other genres
I haven't written in a lot of other
genres
I've done a few things
but I don't know that I could give a
fair comparison but I think I always say
I think it is a very challenging genre
again because you're you're having to
create a drama right with all its
intricacies and levels of
characterization and all that but then
you're also having to write a crime
story so it's you're writing two stories
and I I always
I start you know I lay out my Crime
Story first so that I know I have the
correct plot then I go back and I lay
out the neck the other story The Peril
which is the investigator's story and so
what's because they have personal lives
and they have things that they're
dealing with and so that is a whole
separate story right and then you have
to mesh them together
um and figure out how they how they
inform each other so I love it I love
that exercise in the brain
but if I were writing just a straight
drama
I think
it would be just the one story
and another Crime Story alongside of it
so
challenging
right because then sharp going back to
sharp objects you have Amy Adams
character but then there's a love
interest right and there's kind of
baggage with that and then there's other
people in the town that you kind of get
hints into their world some more than
others right and yeah it's you know so
you've got to kind of develop their
little Side Stories exactly exactly but
then you're always pushing the mystery
too like always you have to have that
whole thing figured out so I like it uh
because I guess maybe I get bored I like
lots of variety
is creating a crime series as simple as
coming up with new crimes or that's just
one part of it if you have a protagonist
that isn't really going to change and
grow then
it's kind of more about the crimes that
they're solving each book or each
episode right and and we've seen you
know we've seen that a lot on TV where
um they you know the protagonists don't
have a huge Arc right they just week by
week they're the same person they don't
have a big thing that they're dealing
with they have their b c and d stories
but you know for the most part they're
they're not changing and growing a ton
they're the same almost the same people
from when they started you know to the
end
um so there's that uh
and that's fine that's and then it's
then though with those series or those
kinds of stories the crime becomes very
much in the Forefront that's like really
what we're interested you know we're
diving into those books or that show
because we really are interested in
watching the twisty curvy crime being
solved and then
you have
um the other where I think
you're looking at a protagonist there's
a there maybe is a bigger crime that's
being solved or they're solving certain
things you know maybe week by week
crimes but then they're actually dealing
with something kind of bigger in their
life we're life-changing like
doing a hero's journey where they go
from zero to 180 and they become in some
ways a different person or whatever
right devil that they're fighting or
thing they're trying to overcome they
actually get to overcome it
so I think there's kind of two
directions
you can take them so
what goes into the outline of a crime
series
I start with my case File which takes a
lot of time I spend most of my time
researching and prepping all this
outline and then make sure I have my
crime figured out all the steps of the
crime the logistics of all that how my
investigators going to solve that and
then the journey that the investigator
is going to go on and then the
antagonist like what journey is that
antagonist on from the beginning of the
story to the end where where does that
person fit in and what's their Arc so to
me those are the main things that go in
my outline I outline copiously with
these kinds of stories
um because then when I sit down to write
I can just sort of like ah it's all it's
all kind of there I can just
pull it up and now add now get writing
because I don't wanna I'm not a you know
in the fiction World they say there's
the Panther and the plotter and
when it comes to Crime writing I I'm
definitely a plotter because I don't I
don't wanna
I don't want to spend my time I want to
spend my time writing not figuring out
does does this evidence work here or
here yeah I kind of want to get that all
figured out first so
I think it's important to figure the
crime out figure out how those Trails of
evidence work how your investigator is
going to run through that crime
and figure it out and and there will be
surprises obviously there's surprises
once you get down to writing it's
it's never finalized in the outline
so what other tips do you have for
anyone deciding to write a crime series
do's and don'ts give it a try like don't
think too much if this is kind of like
your first foray into writing crime and
you're just you're very interested in it
and you love crime just give it a try I
think it's worthwhile for any writer to
to try even if you're comedy whatever
it's such a good exercise
um don't feel that you have to know
everything about forensics or crime
fighting or any of that to delve in
there's plenty of resources
but do
seek to be authentic do some research
get some help if you need to get some
help in places where you're not sure
about things
and do seek to entertain first
because that's that's what we're in the
business of doing so
if you want to be a detective go to the
police force
if you want to be a writer yeah
but are there some overused tropes in
terms of um or just like uh just sort of
cliche characters like the curmudgeon
Sergeant who's fighting with the the
other officers but that's not really how
it is or
um just the I don't know the the jealous
ex-wife right that we've seen or
ex-husband
um or maybe the evil sister right
um you know all of these I think
I think um we I don't know that I
believe in overused tropes as much as
not well played out or well-developed
stereotypes
I do yeah I do think it's okay to have
that curmudgeonly Sergeant even though
that's typically not what happens in
real life because we're not here to
portray necessarily what happens
in real life but
I think it's more of again going back to
why is that Sergeant curmudgeonly
against that detective because kind of
The Stereotype is just well that's just
their roles like it's just his job to be
a chromogen and and to provide obstacles
for that police officer and it's like
okay that's great that was 1950s or
whatever but what if we gave that
chromogenly
Sergeant a really good interesting
reason for being curmudgeonly that has
made me
nothing to do with the police force or
maybe it has everything to do with that
officer and there's some history there
um so again I just think
having motivations for wire characters
are the way they are and interact the
way they do
can go a long way in breaking down
stereotypes but I think the tropes are
like most of the tropes are okay we we
need tropes I mean Trope simply means a
turn right it's just churning the story
in a in a different way to satisfy the
audience's expectations well we need
that like we're okay with that as an
audience what we're not okay with is
just the stereotype the the
inauthenticity of it we want to you know
especially I think viewers now are very
Savvy and we it's why why why why are
they doing why why why why is that
person acting that way towards this
person
um
and yeah so I just like keep digging